all right Max and Sid
Max and Sid where you guys from
originally Max I'm from Milwaukee
Milwaukee Wisconsin I'm from Macon
Georgia Macon Georgia yes sir tell me
about your families growing up I
actually had uh Mom and Dad
uh I was adopting bye
cops from Russia
just bad all around I adopted from
Russia
your parents were Russian well oh no my
adopted parents I never met my real
parents but your adopted parents how was
your relationship with them uh very not
good she's gonna go into it farther I'm
better talking uh I guess they kind of
more so wanted a puppy and they weren't
ready for the actual dog
I guess you could say but I mean what
kind of childhood did you have is it
abuse yeah
well uh nitty-gritty details babe
over here huh
that's I don't know I can't talk they
[ __ ] it up
how was your childhood my childhood was
I had a [ __ ] great childhood uh
comparatively especially the max you
know matches you know traveling
something of a horror movie
and I have parents that still in this
day [ __ ] with me they love me of all
people that deserve too late and not
give a [ __ ] about me and have written me
off my parents haven't
so they're cool as [ __ ]
um I just you know I've I was blessed
and like despite their best efforts I
turned out to be
kind of like a classic definition of a
[ __ ] up but you know did you call
yourself a [ __ ] up oh I would call
myself a [ __ ] up I call myself um
I don't know I've made the best of I've
I could it could have been worse I got
it on a lot worse it's a
I see like um sounds like a good
childhood oh yeah I had a great
childhood you know my parents despite
like I said despite their best efforts I
[ __ ] know this is the same Mama Tried
it's definitely true
my mom tried my Dad tried until he
couldn't
until he's just like you know what I was
sleeping with my dad growing with my
best friend you know like I was like
it's like when you like in like
kindergarten they get you to do like
these assignments and stuff because
you're too too young to not really to
really need to do any like actual school
work one of the things I was like
it was a new three best friends and
number one was my dad was my dog that's
my best friend I still love my dad to
death my dad's the reason that like I
have any redeeming qualities
and you took the drugs at an early age
really early yeah really early I was uh
how'd that happen ah do what how'd that
happen
um me being nosy is easy accessibility
or not not easy accessibility but I just
I was dipping it into my dipping into
people's stashes that were not uh
that uh you know that my parents did
nothing like you know give me weed or
anything like that my dad smoked weed
and stuff like that and I would
dip into his stash and you know getting
caught one summer at Boy Scout camp that
there were no hardcore addicts in your
family oh no no I've got some harder
addicts in my family but you know I was
definitely I definitely have gone the
hardest I've there were addicts or there
were men there were anyone like
none never anyone that would just come
back that would give it to me
you know there's these people that
you know they they it was never it was
never something to put on a platter and
hand it to me dope was not really
something like I'd go look for it I I
made a conscious decision in my mind yo
I'm gonna go [ __ ] smoke meth I'm
gonna go [ __ ] shoot heroin because
like you know I was like this little
edgy kid that thought that Sid Vicious
and GiGi Allen were the two coolest
[ __ ] in the world which they
still [ __ ] hard in my opinion
and that's what I wanted to do I was I
was related to make jokes I said yeah I
got on heroin because it's the punk rock
thing to do now I'm stuck you're the
black sheep of your family uh yeah you
could absolutely say that you absolutely
why do you think that is because
um I like to um
because I don't know when to say uh no
I'm good I don't know when to say no
I don't know when they say now that's
enough
or no I don't need to do that because
anything I like are you addicted to
if I like the way something makes me
feel I'm gonna do it to the nth degree
I'm Gonna Keep on doing it until he
kills me
you know if you've been diagnosed as
ADHD oh yeah
yes I was always like that was the first
one was ADHD then it was uh
then I hit with the uh let's get so fast
you haven't bipolar which was really
more I'm just a byproduct of budding
meth addiction that was I was keeping
doing my best to keep on the wraps with
the guys of you know I'm in akosis
because I'm hearing voices and
what did you drink today uh do what what
is your drug today uh I would say uh
opiates just because of pain because
it's hard to get uh
but how do you get a prescription for
painkillers when you have drug charges
on your record and math it means uh at
Nolan and Crystal Method yeah that's my
it's my go-to the old uh old wham bam
thank you man
and Max you uh you're using as well yeah
I used to be more of a stimulant type of
person just because it made being social
a little bit easier but uh
after years of alcoholism
uh I live with chronic pain so I'm more
of an opiate type of guy you know
fentanyl for you as well yeah
it's good then you go home and we're
homeless so we only got one option I'm
sick in a Denny's bathroom
you guys are living on the streets
uh for the most part yeah we uh if
squats are available like you know it's
just sometimes bushes sometimes bushes
yeah sometimes we live on an Alleyway I
think you've been in L.A
um we just got back downtown
uh
bobbing around SoCal for like a few
months moving back and forth between
Riverside County and Venice and
sometimes downtown
where else in the country have you been
actually been one of the places than I
have uh those places I'm I'm more used
to the east coast and so yeah I've I've
been all the way from what I said for
making I first we all start weird
looking at people oh you're trained
Hoppers which is yeah sometimes but I've
hopped from you know Macon Georgia
there's a freight yard that's downtown
right near where I used to hang out so I
hop from making to Atlanta and at night
you know be up there early in the
morning
and then from there you know it kind of
branches out as a rail Hub you know and
like but I've been off the east coast
I've never actually hopped all the way
out west but I [ __ ] um I usually it's
just like a little gimmick because I
used to use back when like you know
like I've I've stopped by myself and
said I want to get sober these days
because uh
I realize if I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do it if I'm not I'm not but I'd get
rehabs to fly me out west you've done
rehabs oh yeah rehabs I mean I've been
out I've been on a rehab hopper for most
of my adult life and the thing is like I
genuinely a lot of times didn't want to
get sober
but another cool thing is they'll fly
you out pretty much wherever they are so
whether that's down to Florida whether
that's out here to California it's
whatever wow what cities have you hung
out in like you're hanging out in L.A
right Atlanta uh Venice
and uh Little Island Manhattan
yeah you see New York City is nice I
wish I could spend more time there
Kensington too right well I stay away
from Kensington matches those kidneys
those are more Max's uh
like a couple months
I kind of lost charge of time
how would you compare that to the other
cities you've been in
L.A
how would you compare Kensington to Skid
Row
huh honestly he actually told me that
skid rows a lot like Kensington and uh
they're very similar we came out here we
weren't really like hanging around that
much like we were here for like an hour
just trying to find drugs
a little bit
but
why that's a [ __ ] one other thing
it's this clown uh-huh
brilliant I honestly like can't really
compare them I didn't really spend
enough time around Skid Row uh there's a
lot more mess there so that's like where
yeah yo yeah a lot of variety of drugs
in Skid Row whereas like it's all
fentanyl well yeah kensington's final
they do got like prick shitty mess and
crack a little bit of the
yeah that knows a drug that uh it's just
like the like more prominent drug makes
it makes them like drastically different
from each other what's this uh also they
even got blob boys here they're the
black boys you know over on the east
coast or in the midwest you got block
boys no push up that's their block that
they sell on open air drug markets open
air drug markets out here there's just
[ __ ]
I know a guy who might know a guy ain't
got to get ripped off or if you're Max
you [ __ ] ended up having to hit
someone over the head with a uh with a
saucepan
a mini cast iron skills many cast iron
skillet too like how long have you guys
been together
um I spent like six months it's like six
months yeah
we we uh how we met was we were uh I was
in rehab in Redlands California with uh
other place called new Origins is a
badass rehab you know it's uh the peer
support specialist is one of my
childhood Heroes Andy Roy is a pro
skater
um it's one of my favorite this is what
I got to kick and hang out with him live
with him for a while and he's living the
dream I thought
and then I maxed me up on Facebook he's
like yo hey uh I'm with a bunch of
friends and a bunch of alcoholic
[ __ ] her drinking all the time and I
don't drink anymore and it's being I
just want to have someone who's sober
all right cool it works and so uh we
linked up one night hung out I had a
great time I didn't didn't relapse to do
anything I we got home 15 minutes late
for curfew
my phone died I've been that's why I was
late because I didn't I have track of
time and uh well yeah you obviously got
piss test breath a lot of [ __ ] uh past
piss test pass breathalyzer and then um
director calls me he's like hey uh so
The Clinical Director wants us to uh do
two week property restriction because
you're already pushing the envelope uh
like well I pushed the envelope look at
me
that's that's kind of my Mo but he's
like the clinicals right so I want you
to uh
do a two-week property registration or
you can do immediate this charger so go
ahead and grab paperwork and uh get my
[ __ ] so I'm can't Sweet Property
restriction would have entailed go to my
groups during the day going to my three
a lot of the AAA meetings a week and
coming home really fast that
you think I just wanted you out I was
not well I don't think Ron around the
director was a great guy he's a [ __ ]
genuinely out there to help people
same with a lot of other staff there but
I think the clinical writers who I never
met The Clinical Director I don't think
other than just in passing
so she
do you think your problem is more of a
psychological
I think my problem is definitely just a
behavioral thing and then drugs there's
like drugs just
our uh byproducts
you're very well spoken you're you're
very educated I'm like well no yeah I
mean I despite my best numbers I learned
some [ __ ] in school but like you know
don't judge a book by its cover you know
you didn't know I was so educated well I
didn't know you're so presumptuous and
kind of stupid honestly like you know
like him how far did you go in school uh
two years in ninth grade then dropped
out probably a couple months after I
turned 16.
and Max do you think you're on the
streets in this situation on drugs and
all that do you think it's because of
something you went through as a child uh
my parents put me in a homeless shelter
when I was 15.
and uh after like I guess like a few
years of like abuse and like being
psychologically
terrorized that kind of a
definitely uh put a halt on everything
the psychological abuse from your
parents yeah but it was it was mostly my
mother and then my dad uh being like a
doormat and letting Avid yeah
she had she had the man's nuts in her in
her purse very very much so
what was left yes
yeah how old are you guys I'm 23. I'm
22. you're kids
what is this
it was you I feel like you know I've had
lived a lot I've done enough crazy [ __ ]
and lived a lot enough of a life to be
for someone twice my age to show you a
little worn out
but I just I don't know I and PTSD years
I'm dead yeah pcsd and uh
simple add-on some [ __ ] you know I've
pretty much my adult life either locked
upper and uh rehab or on the streets
you know I just I find that you know
today uh like you know I was even
talking to my mom and my dad yesterday
Hotel kind of thing with my drug use
anyhow I've been using stuff like that
for enough I haven't lost myself like I
usually do I usually will get strung the
[ __ ] out and be gone off off the rails
within a couple days
but thanks to you know having something
to focus on having a reason to like you
know
it's really like be
a decent non-like just absolute scummy
[ __ ]
go rob somebody because I don't have
money rather than go go spans and go uh
bump some money off someone or you try
to like you know work for my money
uh it's like homeless for everybody when
they're playing music and stuff on the
street and stuff but you know I was like
Miami Max in my life has really been
something that's been a blessing
like you know like yeah
if it was information regardless of that
situation anyway I was getting kicked
out eventually but thankfully you know I
got kicked out when I did and with the
situation that I did because if I hadn't
been for that
our internet someone who's genuinely
love my [ __ ] life so yeah we might
have [ __ ] up that's long it's actually
clean for a while yeah we stayed clean
for [ __ ] a month on the streets yeah
you know that's I've never been that
clean for that long entire rehab
by myself
are you on psych medications
uh I was for most of my life but not
anymore no I think one medication once a
day for uh
uh byproduct of Reckless Institute of
drug addiction and uh
I find that I'm actually far happier off
my psychiatric medication you're happy
you're off them oh yeah I'm far happier
I've got my I don't gain weight
ridiculously I don't I don't I'm not I'm
not eating a [ __ ] horse and a half
weight of food every day because you
know look that would be detrimental to
me as being homeless
you know I haven't haven't been that
hungry and stuff like that you know like
maybe I'll [ __ ] prostituting yourself
out for cheeseburgers again
you know if I'd be out there
and I'd be I'd be able to [ __ ] just
absolutely I eat and all that stuff like
that I mean like I don't go hungry I
refuse to I'll steal from a store it's
like a corporate store I want to steal
from my mom and pop Corner Store nothing
like that I won't steal from people if
I'm hungry I'm gonna eat though but a
lot of times around here dude there's
enough for good food and trash cans you
know if you like just because it's in
the trash or something it's trash
Max would you describe yourselves as
happy with this lifestyle
in some aspects yes and some yeah
through the upsides of it
uh
I feel like there's a lot less
there's less things to worry about
their responsibilities I never learned
how to live as a regular adult like
I've never lived indoors as an adult
before like this is kind of how I know
how to live yes
either like I really
guess who's forever I don't know how to
put my thoughts into words no I can't
say that I ever want to like
I guess uh
be better off financially because I
never have been
um I don't really see you need to you
think you'll be living some form of this
lifestyle forever
well probably my life expectancy is
really short no I think hopefully in the
future without drugs yeah I think also
you know we have we have a some more um
pissed off at this point today like
we're with that being downtown that's
why I was like awesome that we ran into
the Arkansas
yeah we're planning on head to uh
heading to uh Amarillo and my oh very
very dear friend of mine who's some by
some snowball students and Hell gotten
his [ __ ] together I thought a boy would
die with a needle in this Honorable in
his head uh have you gotten his [ __ ]
together and he lives in Southeastern
Colorado and he's gonna come scoop us
from Amarillo in the next week or two
week or so
so uh we're gonna go uh swing through
him and uh go be able to sleep inside
for a week or two hang out with my
brother Charlie what are you guys afraid
of Max
you pull more context behind that well I
mean what are you afraid of in your life
are you afraid of dying are you afraid
of
Ever Getting clean or afraid of
because there's there's not really much
that I'm afraid of anymore other than
like
uh losing the people I care about do you
have friends
we've got a select a small friend group
you know I'm afraid of like you know
doing this that's stubborn oh yeah the
ones are the ones that have uh
been uh Troopers enough to hang around
still they love me too much to leave me
and I feel like some other people might
be sick I may stick around for
entertainment I talked to my sister on
the phone the other day
make sure you talk about how um like one
of my best friends still I'd say
probably my best friend in the [ __ ]
world is in Shelton and that he's uh
plays the band and uh
she said one of the shows like people
come up to her and be like oh other
people that haven't seen me for years
I'm gonna be like oh how's how's your
brother doing
you can always tell us because like
in my hometown I got a really shitty
reputation
I'm just an [ __ ] uh
uh just enjoy your attention and
degenerate
and uh you know these people from what
my sister says people come up to me and
like come up to her and be like Oh how's
your brother doing just like tell you oh
at least I'm not as bad as he is you
know he's still you know she has some
kind of like us
subconsciously eating over yourself
because like some people come up like
but she's like why do you care
a piece of [ __ ]
but not all that's true you know like so
it's definitely I definitely uh I'm not
saying I'm gonna say by any means god no
but I [ __ ] I've a reputation for
that's a bit more
scandalous than what I really am do you
think your looks are deceiving uh I
don't know I definitely definitely that
that part yeah do you feel misunderstood
uh
yeah absolutely I feel like people
definitely like look at me and say no oh
that's why I guess in my own my life
My Philosophy is there's someone like
unless are they outright or like
coming up and just being a piece of [ __ ]
like like truly like I'm I pride myself
being good at reading people but still
you know I can be wrong
but let's unless it was just outright
being a piece of [ __ ] to me from the
jump I try to give someone a chance
I don't even remember the chance that I
wish someone would give to me
is there ever anything you guys want to
do with your lives that
you passed on to do this I want to be an
artist
um I love that I love drawing I I've
always been into illustration and stuff
like that and uh awesome musician so I
I'm like if you did something creative
it might help straighten you out or get
you off the drugs no not at all I don't
think I don't think anything about a
genuine desire to do to do just that to
get off dope and to get off drugs
entirely would ever do that for me I
just I I don't
I don't see it as a necessity right now
in my life if at any point like God
forbid like you know we're pretty sure
like um well we're if anyone decided
looking to adopt because I don't want to
bring there's enough kids that need
parents in this world I'm going to bring
another one in the world
but uh whatever adopt a kid would that
be a reason I I just shoot my [ __ ] the
[ __ ] up I got one I want to adopt a boy
who's probably like 11 or 12 because
that's about the time they stop being
able they stopped being adopted
statistically access that a dream of
yours as well to adopt but oh yeah I
want to adopt a troubled group home kid
yeah that is if I like make it past the
age of a 35 I'd say well at least it was
always a third of them we said around
30.
we said about we said about 30 we're
gonna um we're probably gonna start slow
down if we make it 30 we're gonna settle
down [ __ ] adopt a kid who's by
probably around 10 to 12 years old the
stage they start getting adopted
statistically and be like okay we're
giving you a [ __ ] chance like you
know come on
let's make the best of it you know like
it's I feel you guys especially someone
who looks like me
would probably be able to maybe like get
through someone a little bit better like
okay I've been through it I've been
through the ring around come out
come on
and pick yourself up off the ground
off the ground you know um
but I'd say pick your bottom lip up off
the ground you do have hope of getting
clean one day one day yeah one day I
it's not so much my hope but I know I
will one day if I ever if I if the drugs
don't come in one day I'm gonna get
cleaned you either you either you either
get sober you die or you are you [ __ ]
um
you Fade Into
um being a drug addicted hermit
um
I think being sober getting sober is
definitely the most hardcore but I think
of all
I think that's so [ __ ] badass I
admire anyone who can get sober actually
you have dreams of getting clean one day
yeah
I think uh like
getting rid of the pressure to stay
clean for the rest of my life
is a like the most important to like my
actual
health and
steps towards getting clean in the first
place I'm seeing when the pressure is
not easy Max how do you think the the
time you spent on the streets has
changed you
uh maybe one out again answer the same
question you should ask I know [ __ ] off
it's it's like drastically made me a lot
stronger being like being a female body
person on the streets will make you go
one of two ways you either shrivel up
and die or uh
yeah become a crazy [ __ ] with the
shoulders of an ax
that's what's done to you yeah
yeah that's what it's done to you
tell me about the tattoo on your
forehead stressful is character hmm
and I could write a whole [ __ ] novel
tell them what it said
and it's a
one of Max's uh close close friends and
partner from I always passed away had it
tattooed on them and uh I did that since
you actually uh for Max right when we
first got together
uh I'm going to one of the private
schools and Christian Schools you know
paid off I can write in cursive really
well I'm an artist right they can I I do
occasionally well I do tattoos for
people and Max did no evil below my lip
which is speak no evil because I believe
that you know people speaking evil of
people with people uh not realizing that
the
not someone that talks a lot either that
sounds kind of like a black hole in the
Kell black uh saying this kind of [ __ ]
but uh do you get you get two years in
one Mouse you know you're the only time
you'll ever not learn anything is when
you believe that you know everything
what do you think most people that are
not from this lifestyle don't understand
about people that are in the streets
doing drugs there were people too
we are people we're homeless people
we're not just homeless typically good
people
they were not yeah or they were all out
here just you know being lazy and stuff
like you know your lazy bomb you know
get a job well first off look at me do
you think I could get a [ __ ] job at
this point
and laziness is definitely not what we
are we're far from lazy we've only madly
nice
is a [ __ ] phenomenal musician we'll
sit here play our hearts out all [ __ ]
day I mean 20 30 bucks
that's not lazy if anything this is
stupid for coming back and keeping
playing
but you know what it's because we love
to play as long as we only do yeah the
money's great yeah I'll either make
three bucks
it's spotty that's the thing it's like
yeah today running into you it's really
saved our ashes because
no it just depends on what day of the
week it is where we are how good the how
good the money's gonna be uh I really if
anyone's gonna people who train
themselves be so good at ignoring the
homeless
that you know it's Max luckily has a
very loud uh very beautiful voice like
you can actually singing voices so we're
kind of like uh why I heard Maxine I
already hear my voice I heard magazine I
was like yeah I'm in love with this
[ __ ]
and um
uh
you see the Hat on the ground with the
money in it that's where your money
should be you know like you you're
listening yeah I hope something was you
know
[ __ ] walk off you know cool I'll come
I got you what would you guys say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
in your lives yeah remind me to get
everyone and give everyone a chance but
don't let don't be a doormat
did you agree with that Max
yeah
yeah you give people doing to others as
you'd have to do unto you until they
prove they're not worth it don't let
don't let people walk on you but
you know don't be uh do you you to get
to get respect you have to give some
some baseline form of it don't follow
First Impressions yeah uh first
impression should get do you count but
they don't mean everything
because you know I know I know a lot of
people that meet me
uh one day of the week uh could be a
very different person than me the next
day
all right yeah
Max and Sid thank you so much for
sharing your stories awesome wish you
guys the best of luck absolutely thank
you